[拍手]
ん
皆さんこんにちはあぶしきがいしゃテーブルクロスで代表取締役を務めておりますよ
オールです
今日は見る間綺麗学生さんから社会人の方
大学の卒業生の方ですかね先輩も含めて評価の過程がしたいと思うんですけれども皆
さん今日何を考えて来られていますでしょうか
私は今日テックに立たせていただきますが
皆さんに一つの声へというものを用意をしてきました
皆さんの中でないと社会課題だと感じていますかというというを一つ用意してきたん
ですけれども
私自身立教大学3年生のときから今の社会の害と向き合いそして a
就職をすることバック自分できるようという道を選び
iphone のチャレ
炎上今始めているところですその中でも私は社会課題に意識を持ち始めたのは小空生の
時になります
小学生の時たまたまなんですけれども
家族連邦でインドネシアに行った思い出があります
インドネシアと聞くと色々な
ウェイバリーだとが海だとかいろいろなイメージがあると思うんですが私が入った時を
さに小学生6際7歳というときにはまだまだ発展途上国というようなイメージの世界が
広がっていました
中でも思いがすごく残っているのが全く年の近い
友達にか形には食べることに困ったことがない私
方やまあいるからゴミ山にゴミを拾いに行ってあげているとか
a 5判を拾って食べたりする子どもだ
でお湯から学校に通う子どもたちの姿は見えませんでした
同じ歳なのに国が違ってこういうことなんだなぁということを考えた私は
子供たぜ自分と同じ年の友達を見て可哀想だなぁという気持ちではなく自分自身が
すごく幸せなんだなということに気付いたからこそ自分にできることは何でもしていき
たいなと思うようになったのが最初のきっかけです
小学生の時にインドネシアに系そして2号て帰ってきてからは私はいろいろな犬には
ボランティア活動に参加をするようになりました
本当にちゃんの問わず参加をしていたので一番身近なところで言うと小学校に行ってい
た会派で大きい20円を入れてみたいんだとか
大栄養家族みたいなところで見つけばも度肝募金箱に10円を入れてみたりとか
自分の小学生だからできることということをやって続けていく
多様なことが自分の過去とお話にはあります
そこからどのようにして社会課題というものをビジネスにつなげていったのかという
ことがきっかけにはなってくるんですけれども
一番ですね大きなきっかけになったのは私2009年になるんですけれども
高校1年生の時になります
私はアメリカのフロリダオーランドという街に親善大使という形で発見多させて
いただきましたこの時に行ったところ
それは npo 法人で障害者支援をしている団体の打ち合わせに賛同しました
この時に私の考え方を180度書いてもらう機会に遭遇するんですけれども
何を目の当たりにしたかというと生涯写真をしている npo 王子私はどのようにし
て寄付やボランティアを集めていくのかということを考える打ち合わせだと思って
参加をしました
ずっと彼らは何を考えていたかというと
どのようにして団体として社会に価値が提供できるのか
その価値もありがたい大家として売り上げ利益というものを挙げられるか
6号話し合いを徹底的にしていたという場面に遭遇をします
傷とかボランティアで社会貢献活動するではないんだ
npo 宮司障害者支援級ボランティアという固定概念を持っていた私からすると
きちんと一液を生み出しながら利益をそう
想像しながら社会貢献をしているという考え方に
まさに驚き思ったというのが
へここ1年生の時の私の想い日になります
このときからですね私は a 途上国の子どもたちの問題
これを着るとかボランティアでやるのではなくアメリカの皆さんから言われぱ
あなたは実物エディある叶えに対して継続的な仕組みをつくるところに役割があるんだ
から
なんかがその役割を果たしくださいという言葉にすごく
枚付けましてここからですね私のチャレンジというものが始まっていきました
のようにして子供たちの教育課題
in 今課題というものを解決ができるのか
して生地と利益を想像しながらビジネスとしても合計ができるかという問いを持ち
ながらですね私はこの立教大学経済学部に入学をすることになります
2012年ですねこの時に留学をしましてここから自分の中でできることを色々な
メキシコからアメリカから色々な海外を回りながら自分にできることをどういう形で
ビジネスにして今夏というチャレンジへきっかけというものを探していました
最終的に出会ったきっかけこれは予想外のところから訪れたんですけれども
私は大学時代ですやっていたアルバイト先からヒントを得るようなことに光って最初
最終的にはなりました
私が4編パールないとそれは飲食店のオーナー様に広告を販売を
羽生いいんでした
飲食店広告販売をする中で上階を知る事になるんですが
いいショッピンのオーナー様まだまだ困っているという課題をどんどん
目の前で聞いていくことになります
ここで経済的な課題を知った私は経済的な飲食店広告課題そして自分自身がもともと
思っていた
途上国の子どもたちの課題これも同時に実現することが出来ればすべての人たちが
windy ピンでハッピーになるのではないかとか
ないまして当時2014年これは大学3年の時になるんですが
株式会社テーブルクロスという会社を立ち上げまして今のチャレンジを始めている
ところになります
本当に一人では出来なかったというところが正直なところですので
知識や経験後は資金面でですもですね
金融機関の方々に悪性で初めて融資をいただいたりいろいろのサポートがありながら
後会社を起業しています今では5年半経ち今年でも君を迎える会社になりました
やっていることそれは飲食店の広告と途上国の子どもたちの課題
これも同時に実現するテーブルクロスというメディアを5名をしています
私たちは通常飲食店の予約
夜ご飯どこに食べに行こうかなという検索をすると思うんですけれどもこの圭作を
テーブルクロスでしていただくことによって予約していただく人数ごとの給食が上告に
ほどっ
届いていきます
仲人レイはこうすると10食も給食
100人で米こうすれば白色の給食
こういう形で途上国の子供たち今は7カ国ですね
いいかんぽ地やバングラディッシュ
ネパールバッグケチや南数がマラウイというような国々へ
給食
を届けるような形を今は取っています
2年半前名鑑で届けられた給食支援数特性色でした
月にですねええ
生食も届けられないようなのが現状です
約500食などな現場ですね500食だった自分で炊き出しができるじゃないかなと
いうことにもどかしく思っていたんですけれどもこの2年間で
具店のオーナー様3,000円前後そしてユーザーの方々が40万2年間で20万食の
給食を届けられるようになりました
そうすると子供たちはどうなったかというと給食をベアてに学校に通ってきます
彼女彼ら達本当に文字の読み書きができずに子どもたちとしては明日までに行くために
ゴミ山に語尾を拾ったり
弟のメイクを見てしまうというのが現状なんですけれども
僕があることによって両親の方々からも
が口に入ってを入れという人事をいただくことができるようになりました
ケニヤカンボジア50人ぐらいしかいなかったら学校に
午前の部だけで250人午後の部だけでも250人子どもが通って
持って式シリーズですね御宸翰読める書けるという子どもたちが増えてきたというよう
なのが最近の現場になります
こうすると子どもたちは言え深木曜蒸すと自分でもを読むことができる力を得ているの
で国の木力になるんじゃないかというサポート後に今私たちの方でやらせていただいて
います
まだまだ課題はたくさんあります
そして飲食店の広告会社飲食店のオーナーさんのためを思ったサービス開発をしなけれ
ば成り立ちませんそして
使っていただくと言うぞとガタガタを考えた開発も引き続き行っていますそして私たち
が大事にしているソーシャルインパクト
どれだけ
てんかんの子どもたちに給食を届けることができたのか
どれだけ子どもたちがう文字の読み書きを覚えて自分の夢に向かって一歩進み出すこと
ができたのか
こういうことを考えたから今は会社の経営だとか
九尾ライブを考えているのが最近の私になりは
ん
チャレンジは始まったばかりですですが私自身は自分が考えていた社会課題を大きく
アメリカで赤穂市をしていただきました
それはどのようにして社会書かないというものを継続的に解決できる仕組みをつくるの
かという言葉と出会いだからです
たい何言われました
ボランティア傷やっぱり継続するには難しい
社会科バイっていうのは中俣解決できないからこそ継続的な仕組みを作ることが重要で
ある
えこういう言葉を教えてもらいました
だからこそ今日とてっとでは皆さんにも同じ問いを置いて最後に終わろうとしています
これから他ねぇ後に本を私たちが今作っていくにあたって今何ができるのかということ
をみんなで一緒に考えていくことができればこれからの日本語モップス的になるんじゃ
ないかなと思っています
そんな中で皆さんの中で感じている
社会
加害者開墾ない3の亡霊のチーフ真琴を始めとして何から自分ならできるのかどういう
ことを仕組みができるのかということを一緒に考えていきませんかということをお伝え
したくで今日は前途に合わせていきましていただきました
課題とどうも吉川かは自分次第方と思いは決して杞憂が詰めてはありではありませ本当
にいろんな黒があるので企業に勤めて社会課題と向き合うもよし
毎日の生活の中で向き合う後よしいい
向き合い方がありますそんな社会課題を目の前にした時
一方後牛がされるような環境づくりができると良いのではないかなと思っております
した悩まずではありましたが本日はご静聴ありがとうございます
どうぞ今後ともよろしくお願いしますございまーす
た